hey Conan O'Brien here welcome to Conan
O'Brien needs a friend sitting here with
Sonam of cesian hi you were staring very
intently at your glass of water I was
trying not to be loud about it I feel
like I'm very like loud when I do things
so I'm trying to be very gentle no but
you were down and you were staring into
the glass and kind of a I don't know I
think I zoned out I think you completely
zoned it I don't even think you realized
you were in studio and how are you Matt
Gourley I'm fine I was just staring at a
pen
guys we've got to be on the ball people
listen to this podcast because of our
razor
sharp repartee they do no no wait I
forgot what we did yeah no it's not for
that reason what about all the research
we do before each podcast
you're really funny if we revealed that
we met for a whole day beforehand and
worked out in great detail the nonsense
that we were going to do something oh
it's all and it's all meticulous
meticulously laid out and it's
storyboarded it's storyboarded and then
there were little moments where you're
supposed to say yeah I'd buy that with
an onion you know and then you know what
I'm saying would you say that line yeah
I'd buy that with an onion that's pretty
good it was it we also hire actors so we
can watch this thing ahead of time and
make notes you know this is becoming
it's a lot like Nathan Fielder yeah uh
his show yeah uh with the rehearsal be
really funny for I'm a huge Nathan
Fielder fan I would love to see him hire
actors to listen to a lot of our
podcasts and then try and recreate us
talking and then of course Nathan's
there with his his pad of paper or his
notebook here is his computer studying
trying to crack the great mystery yeah
that is three idiots yeah basically
killing some time that's true true I
mean I don't I
work well if we had to plan anything
though if we actually like sat down and
thought about the things that we were
gonna say I don't think I could I'd I'd
walk out you're pretty chill now let me
ask you a question are you a chill mom
because I've known you for a long time
yeah and then you have these beautiful
boys now these twin boys Mikey and
Charlie and I'm wondering give us a read
on what kind of mom you are you a mom
who's like it's all good so they so he
ate a gummy what's the big deal oh God
no no I am I am a very like you know let
them live and explore and like that's
their Journey that's the highway they
should walk around it and take a look at
stuff you know there are lines like you
know I don't let them walk into oncoming
traffic if that's what you're saying
okay yeah no I like the point is keep
them alive but I'm not like oh they
dropped they dropped this I must wash it
thoroughly with soap and water and well
who are you doing I don't think uh Gorly
I mean you might be that kind of guy are
you that guy you're not that guy no I
think Amanda's a little more chill than
me for those things but yeah I'm not I'm
not a helicopter parent we let our kid
kind of ping off the walls like a Roomba
yeah yeah yeah are you I'm not but my
wife has hired private detectives
lots of them for your kids yeah just to
follow our kids around and make sure
yeah she's always getting reports you're
worried that they're cheating on you
with other parents yeah
the pictures of them meeting with these
other parents who actually looked them
in the eye when they talked to him and
don't discuss their career in Show
Business
ad nauseam
frankly they look very happy they look
very happy they go there they all eat a
nice lovely meal together and the father
asked them about them doesn't seem to
monologue incessantly about his podcast
and his next move in the business we're
clearly your new children yeah yeah I'm
just sitting here thinking I know what
that's like I've really never been like
hey guys watch the sketch I did that was
really funny now
because you just did that to us earlier
today
no you guys are different oh okay you
work for me you have to do okay and
you're going to watch more
Eduardo queue up 75 sketches I worked on
for SNL that are at best a b or a B plus
but what if they're like oh my God I
love Brad Pitt you're like well I did a
bit with him years ago during late night
here it is look at how cool I am no they
would they they're not and I and this is
a shout out I mean I I really love my
kids for this they're I think on some
deep deep level that could only be found
on an MRI uh proud of me but you know
they think okay he's you know he's uh
he's paying the rent good for him
um you guys are running huh yeah yeah we
are too bad I made some
bad Investments anyway uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
I can make it I just can't hold on to it
I love the ponies I'm always at the
track be great if you saw me every week
at the track and I'm always walking out
at Santa Anita and I'm always tearing up
tickets angrily and I'm wearing a
rumpled shirt and a crappy pork pie hat
that's what I pictured exactly what I
picture yeah and I'm just uh I'm just
mad I'm about two dollars a race yeah
two dollars a race and then just chewing
out someone who gave me the bum tip
screaming at jockeys when they're trying
to get to their car
and horses have gone fast if they'd put
a bank safe in the south
sure we really don't need to take this
abuse yeah so that's that's me that's me
uh no but I I yeah I there I I give them
a lot of uh I give them a lot of credit
because they uh
they are not they are certainly not
sycophants about my work which is really
nice that's nice but you done like I
mean I know Beckett's Into The Simpsons
like you've probably shown him
like the monorail episode well I didn't
that was nice because he found that on
his own oh okay so he just was into The
Simpsons and I didn't really say
anything about it and then I think one
day but did he saw my name he didn't
know I think he might have known but
it's it's interesting he found the
Simpsons pretty young and it's not I I
don't walk around saying you know what I
used to do
because my wife won't allow it not
because I don't want to
she really comes down for my daughter to
find my James Bond podcasts and really
be floored oh my God she will be though
she will be there's a certain age where
they're proud of you because you're the
only parent they had you know what
I'm sorry but but sooner or later my
kids are my kids are just gonna have to
go that's the Dad we got you go to war
with the Army you got exactly
exactly that's the Dad we were handed by
a cruel arbitrary God
no then they'll find little things about
me that were you know that were okay so
yeah I'm sure they will yeah no they
will of course they will yeah what are
we talking about here I don't know I
think they will I don't know I don't
want my kids to see or do anything well
you wrote a book uh about uh pretty much
where you laid bare your your work ethic
and some of your Misadventures what
about when your kids find that book I
know and then like you know world's
worst assistant by Sonoma Obsession
available in bookstores everywhere you
know New York Times New York Times
bestseller you can get it for the
holidays or this after you could have
gotten it for the holidays yeah I'm sure
you got it for the holidays yeah yeah so
so but the point is uh are you looking
for how do you feel about the day when
Mikey and Charlie are walking through a
bookstore and they see that book because
it'll be in print as long as Catch 22 by
Joseph Heller okay no it won't but I
think there's gonna be like you know
there's me talking about weed and dating
boys but by then they might might not
even care about that stuff that's a
whole different generation there'll be
no dating in the future I think it's
going to be everyone's going to just
sort of I think Sexes are going away I
think we're all just going to be and and
sex is gonna go away we're just going to
replicate very using various machines
are you projecting Jesus Christ yeah and
we're going to get real depressed I'm
going to watch our old stuff from the
90s alone because your kids you know
watch me yeah where you're sitting next
to a young Andy Richter wait this isn't
me I'm talking in Broad General
to about what's going to happen to
civilization as we go forward you know
you're going to start taking those pills
you found in the park